when you're the best of friends having
so much fun together the Fox on the
Hound is another one of those Disney
movies that probably has too many cutesy
scenes in it but to its credit it uses
it much more to its advantage the films
about a little fox who loses his mother
and gets taken up by an old lady she
unfortunately though happens to live
right next door to a hunter who has a
dog two dogs actually but one of them's
a puppy trying to learn how to hunt
obviously you think these two wouldn't
get along but they seem to hit it off
pretty well as time goes on their
friendship becomes stronger despite the
fact that everybody's telling them
they're gonna be the worst of enemies
but they keep playing and having fun and
constantly get into trouble it's not
until the dog is taken away for a long
time it becomes a professional hunting
dog that he returns and finds that the
friendship can't be the way they were
through an accident the Fox injures the
dog's best friend and the dog vows
vengeance and on top of that the woman
finds she just can't hold on to the Fox
anymore and sets him free in the wild
this according to every woman ever
talked to is a big tearjerker see so the
two are now enemies out for blood and
try to see who will come out on top a
good setup for a story and they do it
pretty well but I have to admit I felt
like it could be stronger like I said
the best friend getting injured why
didn't he die I'm sorry it's just this
movie would have been a lot more
powerful if that dog died or how about
when the woman is laying the Fox Go just
having some instrumental music or even
have it silent instead of playing
whatever pop song was popular at the
time little tidbits like that really
keep me from loving this film but as a
Disney film it's pretty strong the big
scene after the climax is a very good
payoff and you can find yourself very
invested in it and like I said some of
the cutesy teens drag but I think it's
allowed to drag sort of in the same way
Bambi was allowed to drag you know
you're gonna get to the harder stuff
later I just wish it was a little harder
I don't know maybe it's the sick bastard
in me but I think this could have been a
little bit more adult but as is it's a
decent movie
songs aren't really that memorable and I
don't remember too many of the side
characters either but it's the
friendship between the two of them that
really holds up I'd say it's definitely
worth your time taking a watch
you